this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by nobody
because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists
ryan today we're going to discuss
minimizing
and letting go of sentimental stuff the
most
sometimes the most difficult things to
let go of often the most difficult
and for that reason people often want to
start there like oh i want to just
tackle the difficult thing and i get
that impulse
in fact unfortunately that's where i
started
oh oh that's right with all your mom's
stuff right before i even had heard
about minimalism
it was really understanding minimalism
because here's the weird thing i think
that that
wisdom begets minimalism minimalism
does not beget wisdom hmm you can tweet
that podcast sean
now let me let me expand on what i mean
by that jason the act of
being a minimalist doesn't necessarily
make you more wise
right and what i mean by that is but
once we understand
the absurd meaning that we impart
onto our things once that
that illusion sort of begins to dissolve
in front of us we realize like oh
these don't actually have the meaning
that we thought they had and
and by understanding that the things
become
less sentimental so you could grab a
giant dumpster
and start with all your sentimental
things and just throw them in there
and it's going to make you more
miserable
by doing that without the understanding
of oh wait a minute
these things don't really have the
meaning i thought they had the
significance i thought
they had and that's what i wanted to
talk about today
letting go isn't always fun but it is
always
freeing now freedom sometimes is really
jarring
i have a friend who was in prison for 10
years and
when he got out of prison he didn't know
what to do with himself
because that that freedom was
a bit much for him he he wasn't use
he what he was used to was what the
constraints of the
prison the literal prison he was in now
we've been imprisoned by the american
dream
by consumerism by corporatism
by the desire for more and more stuff
in fact on the minimal episode today i'm
hoping to talk about sentimental items
and we'll talk more about that on the
maximal
as well but on the maximum i really want
to address the problem
with wanting more always wanting
more and trying to form a deeper
understanding there
now when i talk about minimalism or
letting go
is freeing it can be jarring as well
and so yeah i think about when i got
laid off
and all of a sudden i was free and it
was like
i think i was depressed for like a month
because i didn't know what to do with
that freedom
per se i mean i knew that we were
writing
you know uh we had a book on the way we
were gonna go on tour so i mean i had
things to do
but you know going 100 miles an hour to
a complete stop
it was super jarring especially like
i was needed all the time my phone was
constantly ringing
hey can you solve this problem for me
hey i gotta i got a customer who needs
this i
you know whatever i got an employee that
you know i gotta whatever you were
significant and you
lost some of that significance or or
perceived significance
but i got all my i got all my time back
like instantly right
like all of a sudden i had you know an
extra 60 hours a week
now i love what you said you said i had
things to do and if i were to
pin that but you didn't have things that
you were told to do anymore
and so you had a particular kind of
freedom it's just like my friend
who got out of prison he there wasn't
someone
literally looking over his shoulder now
telling him when to eat when to go to
bed
when to go outside etc
he had to make those decisions on his
own and it require a particular kind of
discipline but i think even that
discipline is birthed out of an
understanding of where we want to go
yeah a sort of a rival point that that
determines what the journey is
well today's journey is understanding
our connection
with sentimental stuff before we get
into our first
question ryan i had this you know people
can text us
937-202-4654
we answer a lot of your questions those
texts literally go to both of our phones
we don't answer everyone we can't but we
do respond to some folks including some
folks here on the podcast
i don't know if you saw this one ryan
but this one is from claire stanton
now we we interviewed her family
alana and mike stanton for our
documentary
less is now they didn't make it into the
final cut of the film
but um they had this beautiful family
and so what we did actually when we
appeared on the today show
a couple months ago they asked for a few
other families
who have been inspired by minimalism who
weren't in the documentary he was like
oh perfect well here's
here's one family for sure and so they
were featured in that today show
segment podcast sean if you put a link
to that in the show notes so folks can
check out the today show interview
because you see this whole family i
think it's four kids that they have
and anyway claire stanton their
seven-year-old
daughter who is in second grade
wrote this letter for her class oh wow
let me just read it real quick actually
you want to read it for us sure ma'am
i love this sign next to so repeat the
people at home here's the seven-year-old
if you're watching this on youtube
there's a giant and by the way if you're
just listening to the
to the audio version uh you can see a
picture of claire there hold it up for
the camera ryan yeah
and it says you are loved and then she's
holding up this note that she
wrote cute little girl uh same same age
as my daughter ella
dear reader dear reader so formal
have you ever gone into someone's house
and it's filled with things they don't
use or enjoy
well it's not surprising if you have
many people have belongings in their
home
that they barely use or enjoy that's
why we have minimalism minimalism
is having things but only the things you
use
or enjoy you should become a minimalist
and here's why first of all claire there
is no should
i just first of all minimalists
help stop pollution yeah
i love that um for example if you only
buy
the things that you need or will
actually enjoy you would have less
trash go to the dump
[Music]
it would also be one less plastic bag
going in the environment
also minimalists are happier for example
minimalists know that things do not make
you happier
they know people do man this
seven-year-old is like wiser than me
it's they're all wiser than most adults
yeah i mean
there is profound wisdom in this and
this is what i'm talking about
wisdom be getting minimalism not the
other way around
dude um she she's a writer she's
she's gonna she's gonna write her own
book one day yeah she i mean i really
wish i
wrote this well and it's it really shows
that maybe i'm doing something wrong as
a parent
lastly you should become a minimalist
because they spend
less money and save for things they
really need and want
as you can see minimalists would not
just go and
buy things to buy things but when they
need something
minimalist buys the nicer quality item
i am a minimalist and i hope now you
want to take your journey into
minimalism and become a minimalist too
your life will be changed drastically
wow
congratulations claire incredible that
is beautiful oh man
we have a question from my favorite
canadian city edmonton
alberta canada this question's from wren
both my parents are super attached to
the gifts they give or
gave me they know i'm always actively
minimizing my stuff i get incredibly
offended and hold the grudge
if i donate or re-gift something i've
explained
explained different ways and repeatedly
said i like no gifts or stuff
and though my dad is coming around my
mom has gotten worse
and she's downsizing but pawning all her
stuff onto my brother or not
i don't really know how to explain
myself anymore and i also don't want to
grudgingly keep my report cards and
knickknacks
they give me no joy i really like some
advice on this so ryan the word that
stands out to me in this entire question
is attached she said both of my parents
are attached to the things that they
give her yes that's crazy
i i had to pit the answer come to mind
which would be uh
others attachments are not your
attachments
and often we feel pressured oh because
someone someone else
likes whatever then you know i should
like it and there's something wrong with
those two yeah and there's something
wrong with me if i don't like it
right and it's especially with parents
and so they're offended
and and even worse they hold a grudge
the parents are in this case it sounds
like
now of course there's always two sides
to every story right
but uh if we were to take rin at her
word
then it sounds to me like the parents
are acting like the children in this
case
and the child here is showing the
maturity of
an adult and by the way we saw that
already a seven-year-old
claire has more maturity than most
adults yeah and it sounds like she has
more joy
than most children as well certainly
more joy than most adults because
yeah when you think about parents walk
around miserable all day kids walk
around joyous and we try to fix the kids
what we're really doing is fixing the
joy out of them accumulating things onto
them
now the parents here are doing the same
thing
if i were to rephrase your question i
would say how do we tactfully
and appropriately address loved ones
regarding
stuff they've given us they've given us
that
they're giving away especially those
things they consider of significant
sentimental value oh that's even worse
when a parent's like here take this this
was a
your grandma's whatever yeah it means a
lot to the family now
now it means a lot to you exactly so so
let me let me give you a
pithy answer for you possessions have no
intrinsic meaning
only the meaning we assign to them
so what does that mean now they find
something meaningful and that's okay
you can find whatever you want
meaningful in fact because there is no
intrinsic meaning of life there's
it's not 42 or whatever the scientists
tell us
we get to decide what is meaningful and
so your parents have decided those
things
are meaningful to them and so instead of
saying
those things aren't meaningful what
you're really saying is rin those things
aren't meaningful to you
and that is okay now how do you help
them understand
that is okay well you can't get someone
to understand something they refuse to
understand
yeah if they don't want to understand it
you can simply say
no thank you yeah when we say no
we can also tell people what we're
saying yes too
i'm saying yes to a more clutter free
space i'm saying yes to more peace
i'm not saying that thing isn't
meaningful to you and it's certainly not
a judgment
that you find meaning in that thing it
just happens to be that i don't find a
meaning in it now
there could be a middle ground on some
of these things report cards for example
ryan if if she's like well yeah okay i i
might want to reference those report
cards someday for some reason
great let's scan them all today we'll do
it in fact
i tell you what you could do if you
really want to contribute to me
mom and dad why don't you scan them for
me that'd be a great gift
and so you're telling them yes and
you're accepting their gift
without being attached to the meaning
that they have attached to those things
yeah i mean the first approach that i
think of is the one that i
took with my oma my most loving
grandma she's amazing she gave me that
paper weight
and i was like she's like oh well you're
you're a writer and
you have lots of papers like she's
imagining
you know my home just filled with stacks
of paper everywhere
and they're blowing all over the place
right right and she solved the problem
for you what she did was she gave you a
solution to an
imaginary problem yeah so i just you
know i just said to her like
you know i don't really have that much i
don't have that many stacks of paper
i wouldn't this is a beautiful
paperweight but it's not something i
would necessarily use um
how about i find it a really good home
and she was like would you do that and
i'm like yeah
so i found i mean and she was just she
was just trying to be nice but she was
also trying to get rid of something
um but you knew her intention was great
yeah so found it a good home now with
uh other family members my loving very
loving mother
um she and this is before minimalism she
would
always just just get me the most you
know random things for christmas out of
love and like you know here i wanna
i wanna give you something it's
christmas time here's a present you know
and i at a certain point i was like mom
like i love you and i love the thought
here and like it you know truly it is
true like
it's the thought that counts it's not
the gift so i appreciate the gesture
here
right and i appreciate the love that
you're trying to show me but this is
actually
not helping me this is you're just
giving me things that i have to put into
a donation box or
i have to give away eventually right um
there's no need
to get me any any more gifts and uh
she didn't really listen yeah
didn't really respect so you know i'm
like whatever like it's her choice to
listen or not listen so the next time
it was birthday or christmas or
something and she had like this bag of
things
and i just refused it i was like i love
you
and i appreciate this but i'm not i'm
not taking this home like you're making
this my problem now right
and what i love about that is you didn't
make it argumentative no and i think
that's where we get kind of because
what's happening here rin and it's going
to be very easy for you to now get
offended because they're offended
and now you're offended by their
offendedness and it escalates things and
becomes a cold war between you and your
parents and that's not what we want at
all
how did you avoid the
cold war with your mother yeah no i just
i just simply and very politely and
respectfully
just refuse and she was offended like
because i think there was one it was
like a business card holder
okay and i was like i was like mom if it
makes you feel good
like i could probably use this business
card holder
and she was like and then like she had
mentioned like passive aggressively
a couple weeks later or whatever a
couple months later oh remember when i
gave you stuff and you just kind of
picked and choose what you wanted and
you just left the rest with me
and i was like mom i would prefer you to
not get me anything so
there were some difficult conversations
there were some honest conversations but
uh like you said um keeping things
non-argumentative
and uh just going out of your way to
express
a the gratitude you have for your
relatives love
and the love has nothing to do with the
things but going out of your way to show
them like hey i know that you love me
and i really love you back
and then also uh to consistently show
them respect
as you're kind of you know denying their
gifts i was gonna i was thinking about
saying as you are
kind of uh setting up your your
boundaries yes
but more importantly like you know
basically what i was saying to my mom
and what ren might have to very honestly
communicate to her parents is like hey
i love you but your expectations are not
my expectations
and uh you know just just do not
escalate
that that's the key point there is we
always want to de-escalate in these
situations if we want to what maintain
the peace yeah and we think of peace
ryan we often think
peace of mind right but it's really
pieced
from mind mind gives meaning
to so many things in in this case
literal things the physical things the
accoutrements of
of living and what you can do instead of
saying
hey i don't i don't find those things
meaningful you can also let your parents
know wren
what do you find meaning in what
experiences
might you find to be meaningful so
you're not simply saying no
you're de-escalating by telling them yes
to something else that you
find meaningful rin i'd love to give you
a copy of our book
everything that remains it's the five
year story of
ryan and i we were the suit and tie
corporate guys to becoming
minimalists but in that there's also a
story of me dealing with my mom's
sentimental items we touched a little
bit in our documentary less is now
but there's a deeper dive of dealing
with my mom's
sentimental stuff in everything that
remains so it's my favorite book that
we've ever written
so far who knows love people use things
might be the new favorite eventually
it's not out yet love people use things
will be out this this summer
and july but in the meantime check out
everything
that remains if you want the audiobook
if you enjoy the podcast you'll probably
enjoy the audiobook version
of everything that remains or if you
want the book book or the ebook we're
happy to send those to you
as well teresa from facebook has a
question for us ryan
why does our brain try so hard to hold
us back from releasing
sentimental possessions i would append
that and say just
from releasing possessions yeah i think
sentimental's probably a little bit more
because we
associate emotions with those objects
yes but the hunter-gatherer brain
wants to hold on to everything i mean we
it wasn't too long ago where we had to
um have a horde of something whether it
was uh
you know whether it was food or um
whether it was
you know textiles whatever it is um we
didn't have access
yeah and now we have access but it's
that part in our brain is still very
much alive and wants us to
uh hold on access is the key there you
know i think about food right like the
things that are
most appealing to us are sweet foods
right
and it's because we didn't always have
access to those our pre-civilized
ancestors
as soon as they found a pot of honey
it was all or you know a a a find of
honey
that they would gorge on honey because
they needed those calories
and now like we everything has sugar in
it
and so we've engineered our world
to over consume and that's what's
happening with our stuff now in fact
if you go far enough back to
pre-civilized people
the the true hunters and gatherers what
we find is
that they couldn't hold on to certain
things right you know they didn't have a
couch for a reason they couldn't carry
it with them right
they had only what they could carry on
their person
what has really happened is we've been
civilized to death to
borrow a phrase from our friend dr
christopher ryan
and in that civilization what we've been
taught what we've been acculturated to
believe
is that we are supposed to hoard
that we have a scarcity mindset and so
fundamentally theresa that
is the answer we have been acculturated
to have a scarcity
mindset and part of that is evolutionary
where yes we've evolved to
to use things that are useful to us to
acquire
things that are helpful or nourishing
to us however we can now transcend that
evolution because as you said
we have access to all of the things that
we need
ryan what time is it you know what time
it is it's time for our lightning round
where we answer your text messages
text your questions and comments to
937-202-4654 yes indeed during the
lightning round this is where ryan and i
do our best to answer questions with a
short shareable less than 140 character
response we put the text to these
minimal maxims in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you'd like
and now you can find all of our minimal
maxims in one place
minimalmaxims.com lori has a question
for us she does what do we do with all
the things associated with a loved one
when we've lost them in a particular in
a particularly tragic traumatic way
i lost my daughter to suicide three
years ago man lori i'm so sorry to hear
about that
what should i do with her ashes what
should i do with her childhood items
there's so much pain and sorrow
associated with these processes
yeah laura i'm so sorry that you've gone
through that and now i'm sorry
even more that you continue to suffer
while trying to
sort through her things i do have some
pity answers for you
um some of the ones that we've used in
the past also some new ones for you so
of course we have to start with this one
there are no shoulds only could's
and i think that's helpful for you here
because there is no
what you should do with right her ashes
there are several things you could do
and there isn't a right or wrong answer
it's not something you're supposed to do
with her ashes right yeah i'm trying to
think because she has this [ __ ] in her
head of well i want to be a minimalist
but i'm holding onto my daughter's
things
um the first thing that comes to mind is
like
if she was to get rid of all of her
daughter's things it's not going to make
her feel better
right per se right um so yeah that
should
i mean that's that's where i would ask
myself like why am i [ __ ] on myself
right now
yeah is it because of what other people
think or do i actually think that this
is going to make
my situation better and what she's
saying is she's experienced a lot of
pain so what her hope is here
is that by relinquishing these items
then all of a sudden maybe some of that
pain will ease
up quite a bit and so here's another
pithy answer for you of course you know
this one
this one's in less is now for example
our memories are not in our things our
memories are
inside us and so
i i think when we understand that not
just intellectually but once we
understand that
viscerally in fact on the maximum
episode this week we're gonna have
someone challenge this notion for us
nice they believe that the memories
actually are in the things and so i want
to have
i want to have that challenge i don't
know that i agree but maybe we can form
a daytime with them let's talk about it
but i do want to recognize
that your memories are inside you
sometimes the things can trigger
memories so
what i did with a lot of my mom's stuff
is i took photographs of her things
and i was able to store those things
digitally so i didn't have to store
those things
physically yeah here's a new new pithy
answer for you a new minimal maxim
letting go is part of the grieving
process
i think too often we hold on to things
because
we feel like we're not ready to let go
even though there's never the perfect
time to let go we often hold on to
things too long until what happens
we get dragged if you hold on for too
long
you will get dragged you can tweet that
as well podcast sean
and what i mean by that laura it seems
to me right now and ryan correct me if
if uh you have a different perspective
on this but lori is currently being
dragged
by the expectations of what she should
do in this situation yeah i would agree
with that the
it's the expectations not necessarily
you know her
daughter's ashes that are dragging her
it's these expectations that she's
thrusting on herself
yes i totally agree with that and so
here's another one for you letting go is
not something you do
letting go is something you stop
doing well what do we mean by that in
fact we've got an essay
called letting go is not something you
do put a link to that in the show notes
sean
but let me just say that letting go is
when we stop clinging
it's when we stop living by other
people's expectations
it's when we stop thinking our memories
are in
the things it's when we stop thinking we
should hold on to something out of some
sort of
pious sense of obligation however let me
let me posit a counter argument here
ryan
if we let go too soon we fall
yeah but if we hold on too long we stall
so our good friend jordan no more who is
manning the cameras here at the
minimalist podcast
he is a rock climber and of course if
he's climbing to the top of a mountain
and
he has to let go a thousand times right
you let go
and you latch on to something else you
let go you latch onto something else
now if he lets go too soon he falls
and it's detrimental to him however if
he climbs halfway up and
just doesn't let go at all he stalls
he stays stuck in the middle of a
mountain he doesn't get
to his arrival point he doesn't the
journey does not continue
if you cling to the past there's another
one for you podcast sean
and so lori i'm really sorry that you're
going through this and recognizing that
yeah i don't want you to let go
too soon if your daughter had died
yesterday and you're all of a sudden
setting her room on
fire i'm going to question that decision
and whether that's the appropriate
decision for you however
you're several years into it now and it
sounds to me like because you're asking
this question
there's a lot of pain and sorrow still
associated with those things and so
letting go
is part of the grieving process
yeah yeah i mean i just want to
encourage lori to
treat herself kindly and and treat
yourself with compassion lori don't beat
yourself up too much
um in fact my i got a couple fifty
answers too the first one is letting go
is an act
of self compassion yes um
yeah it's it it is well it all depends
on what you're letting go of too
um but but often that's the case
the other pithy answer i have is letting
go of shoulds is more freeing than
letting go of
stuff yes i think lori that is the truth
i think laurie you've gotta
you know really be honest with yourself
and ask yourself like
the stuff that you're holding on to is
it creating you more pain to hold on
or is it actually doing something for
you
it sounds like there is some type of
pain happening right so is it again is
it other people's expectations is it
because you're at home thinking
oh well ryan and josh wouldn't they
wouldn't give me my minimalist
certificate i'm sure
because i'm holding on to this stuff
like if that's the reason then
you might want to think about the things
that you let go of but if clinging to
those items
if it's preventing you from moving
forward with your life well then
you know maybe that's the better reason
to start to let go of some of these
things
but you can always take pictures of
stuff you can always scan stuff so you
don't necessarily have to
lose that trigger uh because often times
the stuff can trigger a memory so take a
picture of it or scan it
you can always go back to that um
realizing that
by having fewer sentimental items
they're not watered down by hundreds of
sentimental items we actually enjoy
those sentimental items much more
yeah absolutely but we got a bunch more
to talk about today ryan so
so much more but first what do you got
for us here are some
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners hi
i have two tips so on a patreon
podcast ryan mentioned that
he wasn't even aware of how many
advertisements he was seeing on
a certain service and i live in new york
so there are
advertisements everywhere on the subway
at the bus stop
and so i just started saying to myself
in my head
advertisement every time that i see an
advertisement that way i'm a little bit
more aware
of what i'm seeing my other tip
is i would highly recommend the book the
power of habit
it is fascinating for many reasons
one of those is related to
advertisements they
talk about specific companies and
the kind of mental manipulations and
data that they study
to try to get us to buy things that we
do not need
and for me uh just kind of knowing that
when i enter a store
helps me reason through maybe
things that i have the urge to buy that
aren't on my list
this is rochelle from saginaw michigan i
just finished the subtract
episode and i have a suggestion for
kelly and anyone who's trying to listen
more i have adopted a practice of
adjusting my posture
when i realize that i'm in a situation
where i need to listen
for example if i'm seated i stack my
hands in my lap with my palms up
and this reminds myself that i am here
to receive
what the other person has to say i hope
this
this tip helps kelly and anyone else
trying to listen more thanks
all right y'all we got a bunch more to
talk about on patreon this thursday on
the minimalist
private podcast but first real quick for
right here right now here's
one thing that's going on in the life of
the minimalists or at least half of the
minimalists
my wife rebecca she started a podcast
it's called how to love now she's a
registered dietitian but this podcast is
really about
relationships and sex and parenting she
asked me to be the co-host and
i was really honored and i said yes and
we've been having some amazing
conversations over on how to love now
she started this
as exclusively a private podcast and now
there is a public feed so
if you want a taste of how to love you
can now find it on apple podcast
or wherever you listen to podcasts just
type in how to love
or if you're looking for a link you can
head on over to howtolove.show
to find all the links over there these
conversations are unconventional
yeah because she and i we have a
unconventional
relationship in many respects we also
have some unconventional thoughts and
ideas about
parenting about relationships about
monogamy
about the way that we interact with each
other about alone
time and creating space for each other
about desire about
our needs we talk about all of these
things in a very honest and open
way the podcast is called how to love
and you can find it
at howtolove.show for our added value
this week
well since we're going to be talking
about nostalgia especially on the
maximal episode we're only going to dive
deep into nostalgia
some of this nostalgia can actually be a
good thing we makes us feel good and
especially with
music and here's a song that i used to
listen to as a child my mom used to play
it
it's a song from the 60s called a change
is gonna come
by sam cook
by the way we have a bunch more surprise
questions this week like what are some
creative ways to repurpose sentimental
items for daily use rather than having
them simply collect
dust on a shelf what is your take on
memory boxes that parents
make for children why didn't it make me
feel
good when i unloaded all my sentimental
items plus a million more questions and
if you want to hear all that
join us on the minimalist private
podcast this week visit the
minimalists.com support to subscribe and
get your personal link
so that our private podcast plays in
your favorite podcast app
it's cheaper than a cup of coffee and it
keeps our show a hundred percent
advertisement free plus you get access
to all of our
archives we're talking hundreds of
episodes
about minimalism about intentional
living with our guests
really deep dives into things that we
don't talk about
in public that's the minimalists.com
support
you also get a weekly new maximal
episode
you can follow the minimalist on
facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalist come to one of our live
podcast shows
visit the minimalists.com tour to find a
city
near you if you have a question comment
our minimalism tip for our podcast
email a voice memo to podcasts at
theminimalists.com
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com
the minimalists and if you want our show
notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list over at
theminimalists.com you'll also receive
our simple sunday emails or
any new minimalist writings that we
write
for free right there in your inbox and
if you leave here today with
just one message let it be this
love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening
we'll see you next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it